The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
The quiz on Thursday will
cover up through
piezoelectricity.
You've had a set of notes in
your hands that cover just
about everything that I wanted
to say about piezoelectricity.
There are other modulae that
one could talk about.
But these follow quite directly
from the one or two
that we will do.
So we will not have anything to
say about elasticity until
the last lecture of the term,
which is a nice outcome
because you certainly don't
want to take a quiz on
forthright tensors.
You'll spend the entire hour
just writing out all these
cumbersome equations.
All right.
So the quiz will cover up
through piezoelectricity,
including a few of the
representation surfaces that
we'll examine today.
The thing that we'll
be looking at is--
I'm sorry.
You have a question?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
A question.
Well, you said [INAUDIBLE]
example.
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry.
Third-rank tensors.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: Also, we had just a
little bit of that going into
the second quiz.
And we didn't really ask
anything about that on the
second quiz.
So it'd be third-rank tensors.
But you have to use second-rank
tensors to define
third-rank tensors.
So it really will be not the
emphasis, but certainly you
should be familiar with the
early part of what we did with
second-rank tensors.
All right.
So today we'll look at some
representation surfaces to
your wonder and delight at how
incredibly anisotropic the
variation of these third-rank
properties are with direction.
One of the things that I love to
do for problems when we get
to these different piezoelectric
effects is make
up hypothetical devices
just for fun.
So among those that I've
invented, the first one is a
earthquake sensing device
because it's well known that
California is going to split
in half, and half will fall
into the sea any day now.
So if this is the San Andreas
fault, I have developed large,
prismatic monoclinic crystals
that I embed into the San
Andreas fault at regular
intervals.
The bottom of these crystals
is grounded.
There's an electrode
at the top.
And if the San Andreas fault
starts to move, and there is
shear on these crystals,
there will be a charge
developed on the top.
And I ask you to relate the
charge on the top in terms of
the piezoelectric modulae to
the shear along the San
Andreas fault.
So there's a very clever little
device that clearly is
going to be lucrative because
these crystals will have to be
huge in size.
And they'll cost more
even than silicon.
Another device that I've
invented is used down at the
Boston fish pier.
This is a crystal on which
I hang a pan, and
you put fish in it.
That creates a tensile stress
in this direction.
We measure the charge
on this face.
And we put a little meter that
measures the charge that's
accumulated.
So this is how the fishermen
can weigh their fish after
they haul them in
off the boat.
So you see this is really
practical material we're
dealing with.
This has applications in
all realms of life.
So today I'd like to show
you, also, another
problem that sets up.
And I pass this out just so you
can, again, have a look at
some of the questions that you
should be equipped to answer.
So here--
not fully expecting anybody to
do it, but you can see the
sorts of problems
one might ask.
Here is problem set number 16,
which asks you, should you be
so inclined, to think
about manipulations
of third-rank tensors.
But then the second question is
an idea for a device which
the Center for Material Science
and Engineering is
considering employing
here in building 13.
And you can read all
about that..
This is the famous soup cell.
I think probably you will see
some sort of for fun modulus
for a particular device
on the quiz.
I haven't made one up yet.
But I think you'll have a look
at something like that.
And when we do the longitudinal
piezoelectric
modulus for quartz, which we'll
do momentarily, this
will give you an idea of how to
set up these expressions.
The problem, basically, is that
the direct piezoelectric
effect measures a polarization
in terms of all of the
elements of applied stress.
So there is a modulus dijk times
all of the elements of
stress, sigma jk.
So this, until you use the
condensation of subscripts,
contains nine terms going
this way and three
equations going this way.
As we discussed earlier, since
only six of the nine elements
of stress are independent, you
can condense this down into a
3 by 6 array of terms.
The problem in doing that,
though, even though one has
only 18 different modulae to
work with, instead of 27--
that's a considerable economy
in notation, and an
elimination of a great
deal of redundancy--
the matrix form of this
relation-- and I emphasize
that it is a matrix, and it's
no longer a tensor--
the matrix form cannot
be transformed.
Again, there are only
six terms in the
matrix elements of stress.
And there are three equations,
again, one for each component
of polarization.
So instead of having 27,
one has only 18.
But if you are considering
changing the reference axes--
and that is one of the things
that it's interesting to do
for these various modulae
that one can define--
change the orientation of a
particular rod-shaped specimen
that you cut out of a crystal to
different crystallographic
orientations and then ask how
the scalar modulus changes as
you change the direction in
which you've sliced out the
wafer or the rod of material.
In order to do that, you want to
transform the piezoelectric
tensor to a new set
of reference axes.
And you cannot transform the
dij's because they are a
matrix and not a tensor.
And no law of transformation
is defined.
So what you have to do in any
generic problem of this sort
is, for a particular single
crystal, look up the form of
the dij matrix that will have
the equalities between tensor
elements written in and the 0's,
those modulae which are
identically 0, entered
into the array.
And then you have to work your
way backwards to get to the
full tensor notation.
So we'll see this when we
look at the modulae for
symmetry three two.
You'll have to write in the
exact matrix subscripts
without absorbing the equalities
in the notation.
And then you'll have to expand
the matrix terms into full
three-subscript tensor terms.
Then if you want to transform
the axes, which is to say you
want to cut out your specimen,
be it a plate or a rod, in a
different orientation, you have
to transform the full
three subscript tensor elements
to a new setting.
And then if you want to continue
to work in that
setting in the compact matrix
form, collapse it back down to
matrix form, insert the
equalities, and then you're
back to where you
started from.
So this problem of seeing how
modulae that describe
different phenomena vary with
crystal symmetry, you have to
go through this problem of
expanding the compact form and
then collapsing back down when
you've got it as a function of
some orientational angle or in
terms of a coordinate system
that you want to work in.
The problem is exactly the
same for elasticity.
And we'll look at some of
these modulae next term.
You've heard these names
before, I'm sure--
Young's modulus, shear
modulus, and so on.
We'll take a look on next
Tuesday, a week from today, at
Young's modulus, which is one
of the more important ones.
And probably are used to seeing
this in the form of
information for a
polycrystalline material,
which is essentially
isotropic.
The modulus is much more
interesting for
single crystal materials.
And then the surfaces that are
defined particularly for the
lower symmetries are absolutely
wild things with
lumps and wiggles and lobes
and things of that sort,
nothing like the dumb old,
uninteresting ellipsoids that
we encountered for second-rank
properties.
So let's, then, take a look at
how we had set up and defined
the direct piezoelectric
effect.
We set this up as a proper
tensor relation, saying that
P1 is equal to d1.
V1 And then, you'll recall, we
have nine elements of strain--
sigma 11, sigma 12, sigma 13,
sigma 21, sigma 22, sigma 23,
sigm a 31, sigma 32,
and sigma 33.
But the tensor is symmetric,
so we really only need to
enter into our relation six of
these nine terms explicitly.
And what we did was to replace
the two subscripts on the
elements of strain, which,
again, you need if you want to
refer to those elements of
stress through a different
coordinate system.
You have to know the elements
of stress in tensor form.
But we convert it to six terms
by going and replacing the
pairs of subscripts with a
single one, two, and three,
marching down the diagonal of
the tensor this way and then
marching up the right-hand
side, calling two, three,
four, and calling one, three,
five, and finally ending up in
this slot here.
And we call that six.
So that was the notation we
used to get to a matrix
representation.
But the place where all
this started is--
and I'll write just one line
of this to be merciful--
d 111 times sigma 11, so this
pair of subscripts goes with
this pair, plus d 122.
I'm putting that one in next
because we're going to number
the terms for stress in this
order, one through six.
Times sigma 22 plus d 133 times
sigma 33 plus d 123
times sigma 23 plus d 132 times
sigma 32 plus d113 times
sigma 23 plus d 132
times sigma 32.
And finally we end up
in slot number six.
And we have a d 112 times
sigma 12 plus a d
121 times sigma 21.
Look at that.
There's an equation that covers
two whole blackboards.
So if we now condense this down
to matrix form we would
say that P1 is d 11 times sigma
1 plus d 12 times sigma
2 times d 13 times
sigma 3 plus--
and now we have this messy
problem with the 2's--
we have a d 14 times sigma
4 plus, again, a d 14
times a sigma --
2 3 is equal to 32, so
I can call this 4--
and then these terms become 15
sigma 5 and, again, a 15 times
sigma 5 plus a 16 times sigma
6 plus d 16 times sigma 6.
Now we have to make a choice.
Either we are going to have, in
a general matrix relation,
that P sub i is equal to dij
times sigma j, if j is equal
to 1, 2, or 3.
But it's equal to 2 dij
times sigma j if j is
equal to 4, 5, or 6.
And that is something we like
to avoid, if possible.
That's ugly.
And it's going to be a hell of a
matrix if we have factors of
two in front of some of the
matrix elements but not in
terms of others.
So this is something
we could do.
Hey, it's our ballgame.
We make up the rules.
But that's going to be an ugly
thing to have to deal with.
So instead, as we mentioned last
time, what we will do is
to lump together these terms and
define d 14 not as these
individual tensor elements,
but define those matrix
elements as the sum of
these two elements.
And then we saw before that--
we saw last time in our
earlier meeting--
that from the converse
piezoelectric effect, which
expresses strain in terms of
an applied field, where the
elements of strain
1, 23, and 32
appear in separate equations.
And knowing that the same
array of piezoelectric
coefficients amazingly describes
the converse
piezoelectric effect as well
as the direct piezoelectric
effect, we know that
d 123 equals d 132.
And that is from the
converse effect.
So equivalent to saying this is
to define d 14 as twice d
123 because these two
elements are equal.
So we're eating the factor of
two here so that we can write
a nice matrix relation
that doesn't
involve a factor of two.
So making this combination of
terms for the shear stresses,
we would have simply d 14 sigma
4 plus d 15 times sigma
5 plus d 16 times sigma 6.
And we can say, in general, for
the other two equations,
by analogy to this one, that P
sub i is dij times sigma j--
a nice, neat matrix relation
but one for which,
unfortunately, there's no law
of transformation for the
matrix modulae dij.
If you want to change to another
coordinate system, we
have to be prepared to resurrect
this full three
subscript notation on the
piezoelectric modulae.
OK.
Comments or questions
at this point?
All right.
If not, let me remind you that
in the notes which I
distributed last time, there
are summarized all of the
constraints imposed on the
piezoelectric modulae for
single crystals.
And, again, these constraints,
these requirements that the
tensors remain invariant for the
change of axes produced by
a symmetry element that the
crystal possesses, these
transformations show that no
third-rank tensor property can
exist in a crystal that
has inversion.
So the 11 [INAUDIBLE] group,
so-called, that possess
inversion have absolutely no
property and can be not
considered further for
third-rank properties.
And then one must consider all
of the 32 minus 11 21 point
groups that lack conversion
separately.
There's no reason why they
should behave the same way.
Remember that for second-rank
tensor properties we pulled
the argument that inversion
imposes no restrictions or
constraints whatsoever on
second-rank properties so,
therefore, two different
symmetries that differ only by
the presence or absence of
an inversion center.
That is to say, you
change 2 to 2 over
m if you add inversion.
But the argument was inversion
requires nothing, so the
constraints or symmetry,
too, look exactly
like those for symmetry.
And here you've got to plod
through every single one of
the non-centrosymmetric point
groups separately.
And they all have tensors that
have different forms.
So what I'd like to do is look
at one specific one.
And that is the matrix
for symmetry 32.
And that is a point group that
you'll recall has a threefold
axis and twofold axes at
intervals of 60 degrees.
And in your list of the
qualities and absences, 32,
where the 3 is parallel to the
axis x3, and the twofold axis
is parallel to x1.
So we're defining this as x1,
this as x3, and x2 comes out
halfway between the two.
So let me draw this looking down
along the threefold axis.
These are all twofold axes.
And we'll take x1 in
this direction.
x2 pokes out in between
two twofold axes.
And x3 comes straight up along
the threefold axis.
With that coordinate system, the
form of the piezoelectric
modulus matrix has this form-- d
11 minus d 11 0 d 14 0 0 0 0
0 d 15 minus d 14 0 and
in the bottom row d 31
d 31 d 33 0 0 0.
So this matrix with the
equalities put in is obtained
by looking at the full
three-subscript tensor and
requiring that it look the same
before and after any of
the rotations involved by these
three distinct axes--
the threefold and the
pair of twofolds.
OK.
Now, there are many different
scalar modulae that one could
define, some of them serious
and worth the consideration
because of the application in
devices or other practical
situations.
The modulus that I'd like to
examine is something called
the longitudinal piezoelectric
effect.
And let's emphasize, again, that
it is impossible to come
up with one representation
surface that fits every need
because, again, the direct
piezoelectric effect relates
the components of a vector
to a tensor, sigma ij.
There are six independent
tensor elements.
So how can you describe how this
vector is going to change
as you change orientation of
a crystal whose behavior is
described by all of
these modulae?
But I would point out, however,
that there are only
two distinct--
oops, I'm sorry.
This is d 14.
I don't know how I
made that d 15.
There are only, in
this array--
and I slipped a notch.
Excuse me.
Last couple of days are such
that I am not able to even
read from my notes.
So these bottom lines, my
apologies, are all 0.
And there are two modulae,
d 11 and d 14.
So there are two independent
numbers, but they appear as
different matrix elements and,
therefore, different tensor
elements, as well.
And this should be
minus 2 d 14.
I'm sorry.
I slipped down a notch,
and I got some for 32
and some for 6.
And I'm glad I found it at this
point, or I'd really be
in deep trouble.
OK.
So two numbers and that is, in
fact, the form of the matrix
for symmetry 32.
So the longitudinal
piezoelectric effect is one of
the representation surfaces
that gives you the way in
which the polarization will
change for one very, very
specific type of stress.
In particular, what we'll
do is set this up as
a coordinate system.
And we will look at a coordinate
system where this
is the reference axis, x1.
We'll come down with a
compressive stress, sigma 11,
along that axis.
And, therefore, we're applying
a uni-axial stress, which has
just one component of stress.
So that's very specialized.
In general, there would
be six different
components of stress.
But we're looking at one
specific stimulus applied to
this crystal plate.
In response to that sigma 11
there are charges induced on
all of these surfaces.
And these charges, this charge
per unit area, is proportional
to the component of polarization
P1, the component
of polarization P2 along the
surface out of which x 2
comes, and the charge
per unit area or the
polarization along x3.
So this would be P3.
And this would be the
direction of x3.
Now I deliberately tried to
show this sample as a thin
wafer, which has a much larger
surface area here than it does
on the other two surfaces--
a much smaller area there.
Therefore, since polarization
is charge per unit area, if
this area normal to x1 is a very
large area, there's a lot
of charge accumulated there.
It's going to be easy
to measure.
If we make the wafer vanishingly
thin, then the
charge per unit area is high,
but the total area is small.
So there's going to be a
negligible accumulation of
charge on these two
side surfaces.
So the longitudinal
piezoelectric effect and the
longitudinal piezoelectric
electric modulus is an effect,
where we look at the component
of polarization, P1, in
response to an applied
stress, sigma 11.
So it's that simple.
Look at all the terms
we've thrown out.
We've thrown out a whole bunch
of elements of stress, which
we could impose if
we wanted to.
And we've thrown away two of
the three components of
polarization by designing
a specialized sample.
So all that's left then is
that P1 equals sigma 11.
And the relation between those
two parameters is the 111.
So all this is going to hinge
on one single piezoelectric
electric modulus, d
111, and how that
changes with direction.
So this is for one orientation
of a plate.
And I had not specified how the
orientation of this plate
is related to the
symmetry axes.
So let's do that now.
What I'm going to assume is
that this is a crystal.
It doesn't look like
it's hexagonal.
But imagine that this is
a crystal of quartz.
And we could look at an x1
that's in this direction.
And imagine that we have cut
out of this crystal a wafer
that has a normal along x1.
And then relative to this
coordinate system, if this is
x1, the modulus d 111 would
tell us what charges
accumulated on these
two surfaces.
But now, what we could do if
we wanted to know how this
modulus changed with direction
would be to cut out a plate, a
thin plate, in another
orientation,
where this is x1 prime.
And this has changed relative to
the orientation of the cell
edges in the crystal.
The crystal is fixed.
We're just cutting a wafer out
in a different orientation.
So this is x1 prime.
We're going to, again, squeeze
it with a tensile
stress sigma 11 prime.
And we'll ask how the
polarization P1 prime is
related to sigma 11 prime.
And the answer is that P1 prime
will be a tensor element
d 11 prime times
sigma 11 prime.
So what we are asking,
essentially, is how does d 11
transform when we take the
direction of x1 in a different
orientation and, thus, change
the value of d 11 prime?
It's going to change all of the
piezoelectric matrix elements.
But we're looking at an effect
in a sample that is
deliberately prepared such that
we will measure only the
surface charge given
by P1 prime.
And, therefore, the way in which
the properties of this
plate change as we vary the way
in which we've sliced it
out of the single crystal is
going to be simply the
variation of d 11 prime
with direction.
So this is the general nature
of what we will do when we
define any of the scalar
modulae related to the
piezoelectric modulus tensor.
We can change our notation a
little bit in that we have a
modulus which I'll define
as a scalar modules d.
And that d is going
to be d 111 prime.
And I know how to
evaluate that.
d 111 priime will be C 1l, C1m,
C 1n, where these are
direction cosines, times all
of the elements in the
original tensors, dlmn, in the
tensor referred to the
original coordinate system.
So even though this
looks simple--
it's just one modulus--
when we transform it, we've
got a product of three
direction cosines out in front
at every single one of the 27
tensor elements in the
original tensor.
So it's not as trivial
as it seems.
So this is how this modulus
that relates compressive
stress to induced surface
charge will change with
orientation.
But what are these direction
cosines?
These are the direction
cosines--
not the full direction
cosine matrix.
These are the direction
cosines for x1 prime.
OK?
So we can get rid of this
two-subscript notation if it's
understood that these are the
direction cosines of x1 and
simply call these l l, l m, and
l n, just as we did for
the direction cosines of a
vector because we're only
concerned about the orientation
of one of the
axes, namely x1 prime.
We don't care diddly-bop about
x2 prime or x3 prime because
these don't enter into the
modulus that we have defined.
And this will be times dlmn.
OK.
Is what we're doing clear?
So we have defined this
particular effect in terms of
those of the 27 piezoelectric
modulae which are necessary to
describe it.
And then we've established how
they will change with a change
of the direction of one
particular direction.
And we don't care anything
about x2 or x3.
All right.
Now we go through this process
of inserting for matrix
notation with the equalities
built in.
The proper matrix notation in
the first term is d 11 in
matrix notation.
That's this term up here in the
upper left-hand corner.
The second term, the term that
we've written as minus d 11,
that's not d 11 at all.
This is, by definition, d 12.
And we need the true subscripts,
if we're going to
transform this.
So this really is not even a
matrix because the subscripts
have lost meaning, and we're
just using them to identify
equalities.
Then comes a 0.
And next comes something that
we've labeled d 14.
And the subscripts there
are correct.
That is, indeed, the fourth
term in the first row.
But we're going to want to
convert d 14 into a tensor
element momentarily.
Now let's get the rest of the
terms that are non-zero.
This is really d 25.
So the next term that is
non-zero is d 25, which just
happens, because of symmetry,
to be equal to minus d 14.
But this is the true matrix
subscripts, and this is the
true matrix subscript here.
The next term over to the right
is the fifth and final
non-zero term.
This is minus 2 d 11.
And this is really d 26.
Those are the true
matrix elements.
So we put in the proper
matrix subscripts.
And now the next, final, step in
the expansion is to convert
these terms into actual
tensor elements.
So this is d 111.
And these are tensor subscripts,
so this is
something we can transform.
This is d 12.
In tensor notation
this is d 122.
And that's something that has
a law of transformation.
d 14 is really d
123 plus d 132.
We lumped two tensor
elements together
to define this modulus.
Minus d 14 that appears in
the next to the last
non-zero spot is d 25.
d 25 is really d
231 plus d 213.
Then, finally, d 26 is
d 121 plus d 112.
AUDIENCE: Shouldn't
that be d221?
PROFESSOR: Sorry.
d 26, you're right.
That's down in the second
row. d 221 and d 212.
Now we've got something
we can transform.
The law for transformation
is l sub l, l
sub m, l sub n, dlmn.
So And these are the direction
cosines of x1.
So this term will transform as
l 1, l 1, l1 times d 111 .
1 The next term will transform
as l 1, l 2, l 2 times d 122.
And that will be d 122
prime for different
orientation of x1.
This will be two terms.
This will be l 123.
And I can write them
in any order.
So this is l 123 times
d 123 plus d 132.
And these terms prime, when we
change axes, are going to be
equal to l 2, l 1, l 3 times
d 231 plus d 213.
And this last term will be l
1, l 2 squared times d 221
plus d 212.
All right.
So this now is our new tensor
element, d 11 prime.
And that's given by
this sum of terms.
So we'll have a first term
l 1 cubed times d 111.
And if I look through these
other terms, that's the only
term in l 1 cubed
that I'll have.
The next term will involve the
product of three cosines--
l 1 and l 2 squared
times d 122.
And if I go down here, here's
an l 1, l 2 squared again.
So I have plus d
221 plus d 212.
And then, finally, the other
coefficient that I have is
plus l 1, l 2, l 3--
which is what this should be.
And that will be times the sum
of terms d 123 plus d 132.
Up here, you've got the
same thing again--
plus d 231 plus d 213.
And I have a total of
1, 2, 3, 4, 5--
1, 2, 3, 4, 5 terms.
OK, that is how the longitudinal
piezoelectric
modulus will change as we change
the direction of the
normal to the plate that we have
cut out of the crystal.
So these are direction cosines
relative to the
crystallographic axes.
l 3 is the angle between the
normal to the plate and the
threefold axis.
l 1 is the angle cosine to the
angle between the normal to
the plate and one of
the twofold axes.
And l 2 is the direction cosine
for the normal to the
threefold axis and
the twofold axis.
OK.
So we've got it now in terms
of tensor elements.
And now--
yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is it at all
reasonable to assume instead
of taking those sums in d 123,
d 122, just saying 2 d 123?
Is that OK in assuming?
Or not necessarily?
PROFESSOR: Well, we
could do that.
But I did it the long way to not
obscure what we're doing.
OK?
This is a well-defined summation
over subscripts.
And we're going to collapse
immediately down to the sums.
And we're going to replace
the equalities.
So let's see what comes out
of this, if we now, having
reached the zenith, having
transformed the tensor
elements, go down and replace
this with a consolidation of
terms and an insertion
of the equalities
between the matrix elements.
OK The first term is d 11.
So I will have l 1
cubed times d 11.
Notice I'm getting third powers
of direction cosines,
which is going to be what causes
the exotic nature of
these anisotropies.
And then I have a product
of l 1 and l 2 squared.
And this is d 12.
And this second term is--
where did it go?
This is d 21 plus d 212.
And that is what we call d 26.
And then, finally, this product
of three different
direction cosines--
l 1, l 2, l 3.
And we have d 231 plus d 213.
And this is d 25.
And, again, an l 1, l
2, l 3 times d 14.
And the second term here is d
25, if I've done it correctly.
d 25 --
this is d 24.
And this one is d 24.
2/4 OK.
Let's now insert the
equalities--
back to where we came from.
d 11 is d 11.
d 12, however, for
symmetry 32--
I'm going to my handy-dandy
chart of symmetry
restrictions.
I don't want to do that.
That's fourth rank.
AUDIENCE: It's still
on the board.
PROFESSOR: It's still
on the board?
Yes.
Thank you.
When your nose is in it,
it's hard to see.
d 12 is minus d 11.
1 And d 26 is minus 2 d 11.
So these two terms can
be consolidated.
l 1 cubed plus l 1, l 2 squared
times d 11 minus d 11.
So these two terms die.
And I have a minus 2
d 11 that's left.
If I insert the equalities here,
I'll have l 1, l 2, l 3.
d 25 is minus d 14.
And here's a d 14 itself.
So these two terms die.
And then I had d 25.
And that is--
AUDIENCE: You don't have d25.
PROFESSOR: I don't have d 25.
Where did I get the extra one?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
I'll take your word for it.
And I know how it
has to turn out.
OK.
So these two terms
kill each other.
And I'm left with, then,
an l 1, l 2, l 3.
Or have I left something out?
This is d 1--
this is d 15 and d
231 and d 23 --
uh, this is d 2 --
and the combination of
13 and 31 is d 25.
Right?
And if I look at my equalities,
this is l 1, l 2,
l 3 minus d 14 plus
d 14 plus d 25.
And d 25 is minus d 14.
AUDIENCE: Why would
you add this d25?
PROFESSOR: Let me check
my notes and see
what I've got here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
See what I --
d 25 is minus d 14.
And then I have just a d 14.
I don't know --
I see what I did.
I put it in the wrong slot.
This is d 14.
And d 25 is the one
that's minus d 14.
so this term dies, which
is nice because that
cross term is messy.
So what I'm left with, then, if
I check against my notes,
is d l 1 cubed plus l 1,
l 2 squared times d 11.
And then I have minus
d 1 minus--
this doesn't belong in here.
This wants to end up being l 1
cubed minus 3 l 1, l 2 squared
times d 11.
The first term is l 1 cubed.
That's correct.
The second term is
l 1, l 2 squared.
We've got a minus d 1
plus minus 2 d 11.
So I have minus 3.
It should be a minus.
Yeah, that carries
down to a minus.
So I have minus 3 l 1, l 2
squared all time d 11.
OK.
So what we have ended up with
is an expression for the
longitudinal piezoelectric
modulus as a function of
orientation.
The surprising thing is that l 3
does not appear here at all.
It doesn't depend on the angle
between the normal to the
plate and the threefold axis.
It depends only on one modulus,
and that is a
remarkable thing.
This says that the shape of this
surface is independent,
essentially, of the property,
any property that relates the
one one prime to a uni-axial
stimulus, sigma 11.
And you measure a vectory
component in the same
direction is always going to
have this universal surface.
And it involves just a geometric
term and then one
modulus that changes the
magnitude of the longitudinal
piezoelectric modulus but does
not change the asymmetry.
So let's see what this function
looks like as a
function of direction.
Maybe we better wait for that
until we come back because
that's going to take
a few minutes.
So this is what we found.
That is correct.
And we have to now decide what
this looks like, which will
take a few more minutes.
But let's stop here rather
than run late.
All right.
Let's take our 10-minute
break as usual.